India has a lot more internal work to do
I think it should focus a lot more on
that domestic development side of things
which is the real ultimate internal
basis for expanding your influence
overseas secondly if it were to compete
with China and traditional terms it
would lose its not nearly as powerful as
China it would get quite simply beat up
that is not something that it should
want to happen Indians talk a lot about
wanting to be a different kind of power
they say we're a bridging power we're a
constitutional superpower we are
diasporic power lots of different ways
to try and be different from the
traditional great power model I would
like to see India achieve that and I
would even like to be a part of India
achieving that but I don't think that
they have a roadmap for doing sell and
if someone who follows very closely how
they try to use globalization recruit
the Diaspora and use economic leverage
internationally to gain prestige I see a
mixed picture of good and bad positive
trends negative trends it's a work in
progress till they have a road map for
that I don't think they should be
challenging anyone I think the road map
would be some of the things that I you
know sort of hinted at them wanting to
do so it's the economic integration with
the United States such that a third of
software manufacturing from American
corporations now happens in India it's
the integration with China economically
such that they can buy into Chinese
enterprises and vice versa and create
disincentives for there to be you know
sort of conflict between them there is
developing deeper economic ties because
they're already rd by demographic ties
with the gulf countries where there's so
much Indian labor so they don't just get
energy resources from the Gulf but they
can also project a positive influence in
in the Gulf countries for example when
Iraqis or when Indians have voted in
Indian elections or the Iraqi election
as expatriates in the Gulf Arabs have
scratched their heads and said I can't
believe these people who they treat very
very poorly are able to vote in another
country and we don't vote in our own
country so things like this are the
kinds of examples the ways in which
India would like
set an example for the rest of the world
but it needs to do so a lot more
proactively and successfully for that
matter before it can really be a role
model itself
you